okay so we talked about ethics and
security however one of the things that
I think is kind of interesting about
this this topic is that security
actually means something a little bit
differently or could mean something
different in the bot space it's less
about perhaps the security of the
channel in other words preventing other
people from being involved in it but how
do you create a sense of confidence and
integrity in the system that you're
interacting with when it comes to bots
and so that's sort of like reframe the
question for us a little bit we talked a
lot about the ability for BOTS to be
able to self-disclose and describe
themselves in other words right now it's
sort of open season who I said the thing
I meant no not Wild West what was the
other one anyways it's very open field a
playground if you will for BOTS and so
it's unclear probably to most people
what a bot is actually doing who's on
the other side whether or not there are
humans who are monitoring the bots and
how to actually disclose that
information and so there's an
opportunity for us in this room to
collaborate on a wafer BOTS to
self-disclose mirror and I have talked
about this is being kind of like a
robots.txt that describes what the bot
does and what's happening to the data on
the other side which is really about
setting privacy expectations and norms
effectively see we also have observed
through actual experience that humans
generally behave badly regardless of
whether they're dealing with bots or
other humans and so our job is not
actually solved that problem but instead
to find ways and strategies that we can
share for responding to those things
when it happens so for example if
someone starts talking to a bot about
you know committing some kind of legal
act or illegal act or for example wants
to sell drugs how do we how do we deal
with that how do we handle that and
through the self disclosure if a bot
says well look if you tell me illegal
things that you're going to do to
yourself or someone else we're going to
disclose that to the authorities then at
least that person understands the
context of that space and what type of
security measures are in place there's
also an opportunity for platform
providers to evaluate the way that BOTS
behave and so there can be approved and
unapproved BOTS essentially those bots
which say that
do certain things that are evaluated for
whether or not they actually do what
they claim to do vs bots that are not
evaluated and therefore our inner space
or grey area where it's caveat emptor
it's up to you to sort of figure out
whether or not you want to use this
which also i should point out creates an
opportunity for there to be some kind of
yelp directory for BOTS where end users
can go and create independent reviews of
whether BOTS actually do what they say
they're going to do and whether or not
they've been burned or not so some of
the next steps that we think are worth
considering either this afternoon
tomorrow or ongoing is to figure out how
we write essentially what is a code of
conduct for BOTS where they self assert
here's the things that I do here are the
claims that i make about what i can do
and how to interact with me to make that
both human readable ie something like
Creative Commons for BOTS as well as
machine rated readable so essentially if
there's any need for portability each of
different bought platforms can look at
that that file and essentially say to
end-users here's what the spot claims to
do we have an opportunity also to create
a kind of ethical to test suite for BOTS
where that test suite would go through
and have a series of unit tests that
evaluates whether or not the bot does
what it claims to do and then that's
kind of it ok thanks thank you Chris